the question mark it's one of the most
powerful characters in the javascript
universe providing syntactic sugar in
three awesome yet totally unrelated ways
first up we have the ternary operator
the word ternary literally means
composed of three parts
using the question mark as our starting
place we add a condition
on the left side then on the right side
we add a value to a sign
when the condition is truthy but if the
condition is falsy we add a colon to
assign a different value the operator is
often used to replace a traditional
if statement the code in a ternary
expression is far more concise
but you might argue that it's much less
readable than an if statement
and you might be right that is until you
need to assign a variable
a statement like if is code that does
something it's imperative
it begins with state then as the
program's executed it mutates the state
and takes multiple lines of code just to
assign a variable based on a simple
condition
the ternary operator on the other hand
creates an expression which means that
it produces a value
that we can then assign to a variable
this code is declarative
it describes the state of the variable
as opposed to mutating it that's why we
can use const here but require
let in the if statement declarative code
is awesome because it can also be used
in function arguments and in array and
object literals but the question mark
isn't done there in 2020
an awesome new feature landed in
javascript called optional chaining
at some point you've likely written code
that calls an object property that does
not exist and when that happens it
triggers an error
at runtime you could write some code
that asserts a property exists before
calling it
but this can get really ugly nowadays
you can just insert a question mark
between the property name and the period
between the next property
if the parent property is undefined
it'll just return undefined instead of
throwing an error
that's a truly life-changing feature for
the javascript developer
but the question mark has one more trick
up its sleeve nolish coalescing
in many cases you may want to set a
default value for a missing variable or
property name
you can easily do that with a logical or
operator if the left side is falsy
then use the value on the right side but
because javascript has a bunch of weird
rules for what is truthy and falsey
you may get weird results like an empty
string or zero being set to a default
value because it resolves to falsey
instead of logical or you can add a
double question mark which works just
like logical or
except undefined and null are the only
values that short circuit to the right
side making the behavior of your code
much more predictable
this has been the javascript question
mark in 100 seconds
if you want to see more short videos
like this make sure to hit the like
button and subscribe
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one